all right welcome to the second step of
how to solve a 4x4 Rubik's cube at this
point all of the centers on the cube
should be correctly positioned and
oriented so that red white and blue is
in a clockwise direction opposite of red
you should have orange opposite of white
you should have yellow and opposite of
blue you should have green if you don't
have the center's oriented properly you
must do that before going on to the
second step what we're going to be doing
for the second step is pairing each of
these individual edges with its
corresponding edge piece there are 12
pairs of edges totaling 24 pieces this
step is also fairly intuitive like
placing the center's but there are
methods I will show you to make the edge
pairing simpler and quicker you will
have to memorize one short algorithm at
the end of this step so what I like to
first do is to find edges which have
white on them because these are the
easiest to find in my opinion once you
have found two identical edges so here
we have one blue piece that has white on
it and here's another blue white edge
piece what you need to do is you need to
arrange them so that one is in the
inside up layer and one is in the inside
down layer just like these two you'll
also notice that these two have opposite
orientations meaning that this one has
blue on the front and white on the side
and this one has white on the front and
blue on the side so that means we can
match it up what I like to do is to
bring the one on top over to the one on
the bottom but by doing that you're
going to see that we mess up the
center's so we will have to turn it back
what that means is after we match it up
we have to get it out of the way and
replace it with a non matched pair so
the way I like to do this is I place an
unmatched pair in front of this inside
down layered piece on the top layer so
here is where we need an unmatched pair
and as you'll see there is an unmatched
pair there then what happens
I bring the top layer piece over to the
piece on the inside down layer now
because the the newly matched pair is on
the left side of the cube you bring the
left face counterclockwise or up the top
face counterclockwise or towards you so
now you have this newly matched up pair
right in front and then this is the
unmatched pair which we previously put
in this spot now we're going to replace
the newly matched pair with
the unmatched pair so now it's down here
and then what we do is we turn the
center's back so we realign them okay so
now we have one matched up pair what you
do now is look around the cube for two
more identical pieces here is a white
red and here's another white red so we
need to change the orientation of these
so that they are opposite ends of the
cube and they have the same orientation
that they have meaning this one has to
have white and this one has to have red
on front so in order to do that I need
to put this piece over here so I turn
this face down turn the top so that
piece is over there and then turn this
face back now I look in front of this
piece to make sure there's an unmatched
pair here which there is turn this piece
towards that piece now it's on the right
side of the cube so I turn it up towards
me and then I replace that pair that was
here which is now here with an unmatched
pair I then turn the center's back to
realign them okay so that's two pairs
down what I do now is I get this piece
and this piece on opposite ends of the
cube so this one's on the inside up if I
get this one over here in the inside
down we'll be able to match them up so I
turn this one down just like I did with
the other time then I turn the top layer
so that piece is over there and then I
turn that piece back now I make sure
that there is an unmatched pair in front
of the inside down layer piece which
there is so I turn the top layers over
to match both pieces sense is on the
left side I then turn the left face
counterclockwise and bring that pair
towards me
by turning the top face counterclockwise
I'm then going to replace that pair that
was there with this unmatched pair and
then turn the center's back so the move
is pretty redundant you could do it over
and over again it's really not that
different if it's on the left side you
do one move if it's on the right side
you do another move you just have to
make sure that you're not replacing that
that newly matched pair with another
matched pair that's really all there is
to this step okay so here is one orange
white piece and here's the other one
so this one if we flip it up it will be
over here next to it so what we do is we
turn this so it's over here now when I
flip it up it will be opposite instead
of next to it so I flip this piece up
and then I make sure there's an
unmatched pair in front of the down the
inside down layer piece over here so
here's an on matched pair so I turn the
top and then I've lift the the matched
pair up and towards me so now it's in
front here I replace that newly matched
pair here's another matched pair you see
we couldn't just turn the center's back
because first of all we have to flip it
down so now we replace that with an
unmatched pair and now the centers can
be realigned okay so keep looking around
the cube find two more pieces which are
identical so here is a white green piece
and here is the other white green piece
now you see if we just flip this around
this piece will be on the same the same
layer as this one and they have the same
color so that's you can't match those up
what you need to do is basically just
turn one down and then turn the top
layer and now you'll see if you hold it
like this this is in the inside down
layer and if you flip this up it would
be in the inside up layer so now we can
match these up make sure there is an
unmatched pair here in front of this
inside down layer piece on the top layer
so now we could take this piece in the
inside up layer move it to that piece
now we bring it up the right side up
turn the top face towards you or
clockwise so that this newly matched
pair is in front and then we replace
that newly matched pair with this
unmatched pair and then we realign the
center's okay so here is an orange a
green piece and here's the other arms
green piece it's in the inside up this
is in the inside down so I flip it up
make sure there's an unmatched pair here
then you turn it match it get it up and
out of the way and then bring the
unmatched pair down now we could realign
the center's
okay so keep looking around the cube and
find another pair so here is a green red
piece and here is a grill another green
red piece that's in the inside up this
is in the inside down so I could flip it
directly up and it will be the same way
that it was when it was down in this
face so now you make sure there's an
unmatched pair here there is a matched
pair there so what we have to do is
here's a matched pair match pair in
another matched pair this is the only
match pair and then up in the up face so
we basically just turn it until it's in
that in that spot now we can turn this
one to match that one turn this up out
of the way and then we're going to bring
this unmatched pair down and then we can
realign the center's okay so now if you
see we have a pair here that's already
ready it's ready to be matched up all we
have to do is turn it but there is no
more unmatched pairs here so basically
what you do is you visually remember
where this is look around and you see
there is an unmatched pair here so what
we can do is we basically just turn this
and now when we turn this over here this
spot is where you need that unmatched
pair in front of the piece on the inside
down layer so now we could turn this
piece to match that piece get these this
pair up out of the way so now it's in
front replace that with the unmatched
pair and realign the center's okay so
now there's only a few more pieces to do
left to do so here is a piece that has
red blue and here's the other piece that
has red blue so if I want to get them on
the same face this will be in the upper
inside layer and this is in the inside
down layer so if I turn that around 180
degrees now they are aligned so that we
can match them up make sure there is an
unmatched pair here and as you'll see
there's no unmatched pair here on the
top but there is one over here so we
just make it we turn this front face
counterclockwise so that they still
reserve their orientation of being in
the inside up in the inside down and now
we have an unmatched pair in front of
this inside down layer piece so we bring
the top layer piece over turn it up so
left
counterclockwise and then you bring the
top counterclockwise now this this newly
matched pair is in front and then we
replace that newly matched pair that was
there with this unmatched pair by
turning the left face down or clockwise
and then we could realign the center's
okay so now we should only have two more
pairs left so now we have the orange
yellow piece and a yellow green piece
here is the other two now what you see
is that you can't just all right here's
orange and we want to have yellow on it
right so that we can match it up so now
you think you can match it up but there
are only there's only these four pieces
left so there's no unmatched pairs to
kind of replace any of these the newly
matched pairs and realign the center's
so what you have to do this is called
parity you put it so that they have the
same color on the same face so each
piece has the same color on the same
face so I turn this down turn the top
and then put that piece back so now they
have the same color on the same face so
this has green on the front and they
both have yellow on the side and these
both have orange on the front end and
yellow on the side so now the algorithm
we need to perform to fix this is both
down faces clockwise right face
clockwise front face
counterclockwise top face clockwise
right face counterclockwise front face
clockwise and the down face both down
faces counterclockwise and as you'll see
those two edge pairs have now been fixed
so now all of your centers and all of
the edges have been paired up so now
you're ready to go on to step 3